je suis nue mme kremens
je peux voir que pourquoi pleures-tu des gaz lacrymogènes
aussi
je suppose que je suis triste
s'il te plaît détourne-toi je me sens timide à propos de mes nouveaux
muscles
va dire à tes parents que tu es à la maison ils sont
inquiets je suis attendu de retour  sur les
barricades je n'ai pas vu de barricades
eh bien
nous les construisons encore uh-huh
qu'est-ce que tu écris notre manifeste
je leur ai dit de ne pas inviter paul au
fait peut-être que tu es triste mais tu ne me sembles pas
seul  exactement je vais vous vendre à
la manifestation en haut d'une bibliothèque en prenant des
notes y a-t-il une histoire en nous pour les habitants du
kansas
peut-être alors vous devriez étudier nos
résolutions ou de toute façon allez-vous la
relire mes parents pensent que vous êtes un bon écrivain
donner  pour moi
c'est un peu humide
physiquement ou métaphoriquement à la fois basé
sur la couverture des quatre premières phrases
ne critiquez pas mon manifeste oh vous
ne voulez pas de remarques je n'ai pas besoin de
remarques je vous demande seulement de relire parce que
je pensais que je  Je serais encore plus impressionné de
voir à quel point c'est déjà bon, commençons par
le ty  pos
vous